Et bien bonjour comment allez vous moi ça va extrêmement bien aujourd'hui on ne tourne pas dans mon studio on est dans le studio d'Adrien
aujourd'hui c'est différent
tu peux repartir c'est bon , merci Adrien
donc adrien et maquilleur prothésiste si vous n'aviez pas de...
deviné son métier c'est créer des costumes et des maquillages
en fait c'est de faire des choses qu'on n'aura pas besoin de faire en effets spéciaux qui vont du coup paraître plus réels, plus naturels
qui vont bien rendrent devant la caméra. Qu'est ce qu'on fout là me demanderez vous ?
Voyez ça ? Ça c'est totalement un buste de moi, écoutez je suis venu, "c'est hyper troublant",. je suis venu il y à un mois ici
pour faire un
moulage de mon visage c'était le pire moment de ma vie puisque finalement j'avais du plâtre sur la gueule pendant 40 minutes et je pouvais
respirer uniquement à l'aide d'une sorte de petite paille
il faut vraiment pas être claustrophobe je vous assure c'était une belle épreuve psychologique j'ai pu méditer sur moi même et faire le bilan de
ma vie c'était agréable
Le résultat c'est qu'on a un buste de moi même
pourquoi on
a un buste de moi même ? parce que adrien a pu travailler sur ce buste pour me faire des prothèses qui vont modifier mon visage, on va se
faire passer pour une
fausse chaîne de télé une fausse émission on va aller dans la rue demander aux gens ce qu'ils pensent de moi même alors que je
serai devant eux.
Ça va etre hyper intéressant d'avoir l'avis des gens sans filtre avec une honnêteté
extrême puisqu'il pense pas que je suis devant eux étant donné que je suis sous un déguisement de
présentateur télé, je me retrouvais avec ses veuch (cheveux)
avec des lunettes, avec tous mes traits de visage déformé ça va être un grand moment.
c'est parti pour 4/5 heures de maquillage on y va.
Bienvenue sur youtube tv mec je me reconnais pas ma gueule ça me stress de ouf
J'ai une belle calvitie, on va pas ce mytho tu me fais bader mec,
j'étais pas censé voir ça avant d'avoir 50 ans mais bon on va maintenant sortir demander aux gens ce qu'ils pensent de youtube
on verra enfin
l'avis des gens, le vrai avis des gens et c'est parti on suit henry je vais changer ma démarche change la démarche
Je suis obligé de changer ma démarche.
Bonjour les jeunes vous avez deux minutes pour la télé on fait une petite émission sur ce que pensent les gens des gros youtubers, vous
en connaissez vous en regardez ? qui vous suivez sur youtube ?
mister JD, Seb La frite, hugo tout seul je crois. (Transition)
domingo (Transition),  joueur du grenier, Joueur du grenier ? ok.
Joueur du grenier.. et toi ?
Alors tout le monde est joueur du grenier ya qu'lui qui existe hein d'accord on a compris.
je vous vois partir attention vous êtes en train de fuir
j'ai droit à deux questions
Oh la vache elle m'a eu elle est forte. Qui te fait rire dis moi ? On veut des noms ici dans cette rubrique.
Des noms ? alors franchement moi je suis fan de ludovic, lui c'est un mec mais alors il est fantastique.
Je connais il fait comme moi en mieux. Greg guillotain et ses caméras cachées , ses pranks elles sont excellentes. (Transition)des américains. Ok comme qui ?
Logan paul..Logan Paul ? Ah mon dieu! Qu'est ce que tu penses de cyprien ? Franchement cyprien j'aime bien.
Il fait des bons tutos, il fait.. il fait tout.
il fait des tutos quoi ? des tutos...
cyprien norman tout ça non ?
:Vous avez un masque ?:
j'ai des problèmes de peau. Avant il faisait des tutos mais je crois la maintenant il a arrêté.
ah oui ! il avait fait un truc pour faire un calendrier en bois tu l'avais vu ?ouais c'est ça je crois que c'est ça
Est-ce que cyprien ? Non.
t'aime pas ? non c'est trop.. ça fait trop longtemps
C'est vieillot ? Ça fait un peu beaucoup c'est toujours un peu pareil.
Tu préfères cyprien ou norman ? non je préfère cyprien quand même. Cyprien ouais...
ouais norman en fait. c'est un peu.. il est pas très beau en plus. Ouais au calme au calme il est pas très beau. (Transition) Moi je préfère norman
norman à cyprien ? ouais
ouais je préfère mais après moi je regarde pas trop les trucs comme ça je regarde plus les cover et tout ça.
Ah t'es dans la musique ? est ce que tu veux nous chanter un truc ? :Chante:
Et toi tu rigoles toi putain tu va t'en prendre une. Non mais ça va pas là oh ! (Transition) le meilleur le meilleur :
le woop et mister v
le woop et mister v t'es aller voir leurs spectacles ?
Non jamais. Eh bah alors ! (Transition) y'a quoi ? y'a squeezie aussi tu connais ? Squeezie je suis moins fan. Imature ? Ouai c'est ça.
c'est assez chiant je suis d'accord. (Transition) c'est imature un peu c'est ça ? Ouai je sais pas
je regarde pas ses vidéos. Elles sont longues aussi c'est chiant. c'est long, c'est chiant et avec sa tête un peu...
Il t'exaspère lui ça se voit il t'exaspère complètement. (Transition) vous savez il y avait très peu de gens en france qui ont 10 millions d'abonnés
le prochain s'appelle squeezie et on prend un peu la vie des gens vis-à-vis de ce qu'ils en pensent
mais bon tu m'as dit que c'était un peu un con donc. :non j'ai pas dis ça:
si tu l'as dit on a les images de toute façon. :Je suis personne pour juger:
Mais tu peux il n'y a pas de problème, dit que c'est tu veux. Tu peux dire que c'est un petit enculé, personne va te frapper ici
Squeezie ça va j'aime bien. :non j'aime bien:
il y en a qui m'ont dit que c'était un peu un gamin quand même. Ouai c'est un gamin mais c'est drôle.
Tu sais que tu ressembles au méchant dans star wars 7, on te l'as dejà dit ?  Je l'ai pas vu mais merci
je prends ça comme un compliment
tu peux mimer un sabre-laser voir? qu'est ce que tu penses de squeezie ?
Squeezie, ah squeezie ah va y il ma deçu ces derniers temps. Franchement, parce qu'il fait des clip et tout.
Et il chante comme une merde hein ?
Voilà c'est ca, même avec l'autotune dessus ça marche pas.
Notre étude c'est pour une vidéo sur la chaîne youtube de squeezie. Ah ouai ?
puisque c'est moi.. non mais ahah.
Y'a moyen tu as vu la gueule que j'ai quand même? (Transition) ok si je me dis que je suis squeezie vous me croyez ? non.
je parle comme "moi"
quoi alors ? il n'y a pas mille personnes qui parlent comme moi : je chante comme plein de gens je fais plein de trucs comme:
Putain mais elle est incroyable (Transition) Il y a qui d'autre.. il y a  squeezie ouais je connais
Tu en penses quoi ?
Ton regard il était génial vieu. A un moment il a fait c'est ça c'est lui.
Tu veux me questionner ? vas-y vas-y. Je réponds à toutes les questions. Nom/Prénom ? Lucas Hauchard. Frère  ? Florent Hauchard.
Année de naissance ? 27 Janvier 1996 à Vitry sur Seine. :ok c'est bon t'as gagné:
Mais c'est moi bordel. Qu'est-ce tu veux que je fasse ?
parle un peu moins vite dès fois dans tes vidéos parce qu'on comprend pas tout mais sinon c'est bien j'aime bien. ok quoi d'autre vas-y ?
j'écoute vas-y faites moi progresser donner moi pleins de conseils.
:Euhhhh: ça c'est un bon conseil ça.(Transition) Et que toi tu continues les vidéos supers interessantes et pas trop longues.
Fin du test les amis j'en peux plus de cette gueule de merde pourquoi je parle encore dans ce micro bordel y'en a un deuxième sur la caméra.
Les amis c'est un exercice difficile je vais pas vous mentir on a fait des rencontres trop marrantes. il ya même eu
des gens qui voulaient pas être dans la vidéo mais avec qui on a pu échanger c'était hyper intéressant.
Dans l'ensemble c'est pas mauvais les gens aiment bien les vidéos donc c'est
plaisant pour moi même si certaines personnes kiffaient pas trop les vidéos c'était marrant on a vu vraiment l'avis des gens
purs et durs sur les différents youtubers et tous c'étaient trop intéressant. Merci à vous d'avoir regardez la vidéo, n'hésitez pas
à l'aimer comme d'habitude. Moi j'ai envie de m'arracher la peau,
j'en peux plus.
Oh frère, j'ai une gueule c'est encore pire qu'avant vas-y je veux récupérer ma calvitie plus tard j'ai honte.